we are pleased to have back here in
studio man that you watch every single
Sunday on Fox as well as seeing him
inside of Canton in bust form he is Pro
Football Hall of Famer Howie long good
to see how we could see you did a great
job in Ken thank you like really at the
Civic Center dinner which is I pre shot
for the city for the Hall of Fame it's a
major deal and it's it's a tough ask and
you did a great job I really appreciate
that that really that really makes my
day because I love that that jacket
ceremony to me is well it's not pretty I
think it's kind of its kind of replacing
Saturday as the most emotional event at
the Pro Football Hall of Fame that the
guys when they get the jackets as
opposed to making speeches is when
they're realizing at first and they
don't have the nervousness of having to
deliver a speech all they got to do is
put one arm in a sleeve yeah then
another ominous leaving the speech is uh
is a bear it really is because you're
you're being asked to one you have to
choose your presenters and your
presenters should be in in terms of
footballs what was yours my defensive
line coach or a legged who I you know
he's Michael Strahan defensive line
coach and we both joke all the time
Michael has liked we joke Michael has 14
jobs and y-yes he does every figure
that's great I love him and he's
fabulous at it but we laughed at it with
no oral Leggett
there's no Howie long and there's no
Michael Strahan so it should be the
person that's most responsible for you
being there and and it was even the
event was even longer and they've tried
to taper it down you know the the
presenters would give sometimes ten
fifteen minute speeches
well I remember Steve Young's dad grit
got up there that's a great name great
young and I want to be great yeah grit
long grit young got up there and his
speech was longer than the one that
Steve gave after his because grit when
over every single slight that his son
had received been throughout his whole
career word that he was told he could
not well and as an inductee you want to
you know you're going in but you know
all the friends all the teammates
exactly with all the coaches that you've
played under you know the fans the high
school teacher you know anyone that's
impacted your life you don't want to
leave anyone out and it's it's a
daunting task and and you know one of
the many things I love about the Hall of
Fame is that it's a completely random
mix of people with whom you get inducted
and you got inducted with who who was in
Joey Montana Ronnie Lott Dan Rooney and
Dave Wilcox ooh
we've remained i Ronnie and I came up
same year and Ronnie was extremely nice
to me when I was coming out of Villanova
and you know I was a kid in the corner
nobody talked to it what was then a kind
of a an abbreviated combine in Tampa Bay
and asked how you felt they want like
this you know how do you feel good no
x-rays though 40-yard dash that kind of
thing and Joe who I had competed against
for a number of years and Dave Wilcox
and his family and our family have
remained really close friends and and
the group that for example that went in
this year that group will always have a
special relationship because because
they went in together it's the class of
2000 so the you and Dave Wilcox really
had no relationship before that we know
I you know what I'm not a I should be
more of a historian of the game but I
grew up playing hockey I grew up in
Boston and my dream was to play in the
NHL and be Bobby Orr so in many ways my
career has been a disappointment I'd
love that you know I didn't know Dave
Wilcox Dave Wilcox was a big bad man who
played for the San Francisco 49ers and
was one of the few players from that era
who might have been able to translate to
today's game like corners translate well
wide receivers
quarterbacks they translate well but for
example let's say Joe Greene was 268
playing on the notes that guy's 340 now
yeah and let's think about that
Terry's offensive line was 251 across
the board the biggest offensive line in
the league average 323 so if you're not
giving in to the realization that
today's game is bigger stronger and
faster from my perspective because I
know I live it in my house it you know I
see Kyle walks in the kitchen and boxer
shorts or Chris walks and Evoque I'd
look like that mr. robot yeah and it's
funny that you mentioned Mean Joe green
because I saw him at at the at the hall
he's the best and but it's his teammate
Mel Blount looks like he could give you
some snaps now when you talk about size
Gary and strange cowboy hat and the boot
oh my gosh Bela walks in you go who's
the linebacker but you have to remember
that was there was no 5-yard it was true
bump and run and Maul you down the field
you know Willie Brown Mel Blanc they
were there were corners like that in
today's game you can't do that so I'm
not well they change the rules we have
they changed rules because of it and you
believe it when you see him I mean my
key key is he is the real deal I mean
with how he lay that all-time and Hall
of Famers say that to each other and
look at know do they really know how he
longed here in the Rich Eisen show
studio you mentioned Kyle and Chris Kyle
got kicked out of practice recently
because he keep his hands to himself
yeah and when you think of that yeah he
he's kind of get it under control you
know it's one of those things where you
know you're coming back from injury and
you're switching positions and you know
maybe you're not where you want to be
right now he's getting his first live
action since the surgery and you know
I've seen it up close and personal in
our own house you know it's just you
know if when it got to the point where
it's you know you start hitting 290 310
320 you know I need 10 minutes to
stretch at a minimum every day to break
it break it up
and you know if it happens quick we're
in trouble because I could fall apart
right there I'm a Humpty Dumpty right on
the floor with these guys yeah yeah and
then Chris is in Philly now yeah gonna
go see him today how about that he's in
he's in the City of Brotherly Love where
we Diane and I both went to school at
Villanova and have so many really close
friends and we're excited about that for
him and he's I think he's enjoying it
right now and last we spoke was before
the Super Bowl where you were kind of a
nervous wreck and man it was it was you
know you're not been doing this long
time I bet I've been doing it 23 years
hard to believe it had Fox in the studio
and it was the first time in 23 years
I've struggled to be present I was fine
when we had our downtown location but as
soon as we walked into the stadium it
hit me and I was present there but I
wasn't it was the first time in 23 years
I've done you know covered games where
the kids have played and Chris had you
know it narrowed it down to three four
teams and he loved Atlanta and loved to
love the head coach down there and made
the decision to go to New England and I
kind of pushed him a little bit towards
New England and here it wasn't a third
quarter I could get 28 3 or something
like that and I was I can't help him
with his biology is chemistry but the
one thing that I would hope I could help
him with was his football and here I'd
pushed him away from Atlanta to New
England and they're getting blown out in
Super Bowl and I felt like the worst dad
in the world
it was and the swing emotionally in the
second half it was it was a rainbow of
emotions and I must said oh my god
standing by myself in the end zone 30
times in the second half leading into
the overtime it was will never see a
game like that again sir I agree
we will not see another game like that
28 to 3 and then the final score beyond
overtime went run the ball run the ball
I still to say thank you for not running
the vault well I mean Seattle Seahawks
fans are listening you say that's saying
our man
for their Super Bowl loss in England
Patriots yeah they look pretty good
yesterday yeah they did
oh they sure did but when they're when
they're right mentally and physically
Seattle's pretty special group well I'm
going to take a break and come back and
ask you about the 2017 NFL season but
before we do I would be remiss if I
didn't ask you about Charlottesville and
your son Chris in particular put some
comments over that both Kyle and and
Chris put out some comments that we're
very moving to me obviously since
Charlottesville is their hometown and
you raised your kids there I just what
did you think about what we saw over the
weekend I was shocked and horrified you
know you have to understand
Charlottesville Charlottesville we when
we left LA we wanted to find a place to
raise the boys and looked all across
country this is pre kind of you know
accessing the internet and in chamber of
commerce temperature you know kind of
people that are in the community and it
is as fine a place to live with as
caring and giving a group of people as
you could find and for that kind of hate
and and that's what it is it's hate and
if that kind of device miss to be
present in your town for people to be
injured one young lady 32 year old woman
lost your life and and I think that's
the age of our oldest son Chris and it's
just horrible
it is horrible because it you know I
mean I um chol fought in World War two
we all know people who fought World War
two and we thought that this fight
against Nazism and hatred and white
supremacy was complete on that front
and now Charlottesville in a ways that
name will be associated with it well and
I did in a different way than having
grown up in Boston went through the
busing riots in Boston in high school
when there was be segregation and that
was a really really disturbing time and
then out here in LA towards the end of
my career had the rights out here the
Rodney King riots and went through that
and I thought you know Charlottesville
is as far away from all of that
as you can get and for that to happen
there is a stark reminder that you know
there there are still elements out there
while you raised your kids right man
that's for damn sure
yeah they got a good mama yeah I try but
you know you you you you guys the two of
you together good good people and that's
why I'm always able to have you here on
the show many many other ways let's take
a break we're back in 60 seconds with
Pro Football Hall of Famer how long will
hit the 2017 football season that's
coming up next
okay welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
we've got David Shaw of Stanford Dabo
Swinney of Clemson still to call in and
Fred Dreyer
it's coming by the studio how he'll pull
his cool guy hunter yeah he's a cool guy
and you know he think about it athletes
have made the transition yeah you know a
gazillion years ago this is a guy who
you know made the transition own
property you know production rights etc
Fredrick yeah smart guy yeah playing
here in the Los Angeles Ryan I think all
the defensive ends are nice Jordan I
like it now you're out here in Los
Angeles because Fox just had its 2nd
level seminar IMAX seminar in advance of
the the National good wall League season
there was going on any time you know
you've got Dean Blandino Mike Pereira
doing rules and it's you know it rules
in the NFL's like that it's like the
budget for 2017 you ever seen that on
the fence like a repeat take your tail
is like 2 feet tall that's what it is
and for them to break it down and in
simplistic terms that we can all
understand is great but but for me the
highlight of the seminar was David Hill
our kind of founder and the architect of
Fox Sports you just got the Roselle
award I just got the Roselle award as a
matter of fact and you did a fabulous
job again there and he mentioned that to
me too and he and Jerry Jones sat down
on stage and did a kind of a distant
conversation and about halfway through
it they call Jimmy up and Jimmy and
Jerry sat there and told stories and you
know that's a fascinating relationship
and a fascinating time in our
history this happened at your simple ass
yesterday rich I'm telling you it was as
good a 30 minutes of conversation as
I've ever witnessed
in sports it was so much fun and those
guys need to you know there needs to be
a kind of a thawing of you know and I
think there is I think a lot of its
blown out of proportion but I think it's
important for one for them to you know
understand the significance of the the
impact they had on the history of the
NFL and for them to not enjoy that and
and relish that as to partners because
that's really what they were in it and
and Jimmy in my mind and I think all the
cowboys minds belongs in the Ring of
Honor down there and I'm hopeful that
that happens and that's the first step
and then and then there's Canton I mean
Jimmy Anson has as a resume for Canton
there's no question about that and I
know I know the reason why he was in
Canton this years because he presented
JC a sailor and if it wasn't for the
parting of the ways between Jimmy and
Jerry he might not have ever had that
relationship with Jason Taylor and so
many other relationships that he he
holds near and dear that said a part of
me thinks Jimmy might might think if I
he had that third ring if he had the
third ring that Switzer got he would
already be in the Hall of Fame right now
I I'm not sure that he's probably worked
that through he might have worked out
three and said I'm not sure we don't
really Kimmy doesn't want to talk about
it and and I respect that
are we advocates of Jimmy going into the
Hall of Fame for short areas Michael and
then we have a great group and we're
fortunate like you do and you want the
best for them and certainly you had a
you had a parade of David this year this
year with TD and NZ and crass yeah and
TD such a such a nice guy he is I love
those guys and you have love for your
your your on-air mates in the same way
that we do and that's what that's what
makes good TV and yes special at this
symposium did you leave a seat for
Cutler like sort of the way that Jerry
Glanville leaves they actually that gets
rid of us they did a really funny video
and you know
hey listen the perfect situation came up
he had his best season I think of his
career a couple years ago under Adam
GaSe in Chicago and their friends I
think Adam GaSe went to his retirement
party and I and I think he viewed it as
one more opportunity to maybe change
people's perspective and and maybe I'm
putting too much into the value of that
and in just him wanting to go out with a
bang
it's interesting if it was anybody else
like if this was Favre right we'd be
like man he loves the game he loves the
game he can't quit the game with Cutler
it's like that's a ten million dollar
paycheck he's doing this for that people
do not believe that he loves the game to
the point where he can't quit it and yet
that may just be the the underlying
issue it's not saying he's an enigma
wrapped in a riddle
I mean JJ is that I mean I I've seen the
other side of jr. my son Kyle played
with Jay and loves day you know I I told
Kyle okay so remember that is kind of
funny and Jake to give you kind of
there's more oft than than there is on
the surface with Jay than people think
and you know he has a personality he's
actually a funny guy but he's not you
know Eli Manning Troy but not
demonstrative rah-rah jump up and down
rise but you know led in their own way
and and leelai' still leads but because
I remember that one famous game on like
a Thursday night or a Monday night where
he was on the sideline and he grabbed
one of his offensive linemen by the neck
Jay Cutler and this before Kyle got
there and and you know I the the
primitive side of me came back for a
minute he was drafted in Chicago and I
just said to look quarterback and yell
at you that's fine you know he gets
within his rights I've I've heard it
I've seen it that's fine he puts his
hands on you I don't care if it's Monday
Night Football Sunday Night Football
Tuesday Night Football you choke him
and unbeknownst me he told Jay haha man
and then they were playing I think that
Jess on Monday night and Kyle was
getting into a skirmish with a couple of
defensive tackles after the plan Jay
grabbed him from behind and Jay made a
point of coming up to me in the tunnel
and saying hey mr. long I'm like mr.
long a mr. long by the way you know I
wanted you to know I was just trying to
help Kyle out when I grabbed him I
wasn't grabbing him by the collar and I
at the time I didn't think it through
but you know what he was really saying
was I know you told your son to choke me
Hey look everybody who's come across
Cutler in person and outside of the
locker room thinks he's a individual you
know and we'll just see how he does in
Miami unfortunately for I was on record
to seeing what was going to happen on
Fox because I think that you know I
think people were going to be surprised
at what Jay was going to bring since
sure and I agree with you there and I
look forward to Romo doing the game's on
CBS I've got Howie long here so I want
to hit some of these issues for the 2017
season Jerry Jones has been described as
furious as to what's gone down with
Ezekiel le and you just saw him as you
just mentioned at the symposium did he
let any thoughts loose I didn't hear any
didn't hear anything and he wasn't asked
and it wasn't I don't think that was on
the agenda it was more of a conversation
of you know the Fox Sports starting in
1994 with a pad of paper and we were Fox
Sports and we had nobody and so so we he
didn't talk about it I don't have and
I'm not sure what you're privy to I
don't have all the facts on what led the
league - you know levy those six game
suspension I do know this and I Roger
also spoke at our seminar and I think
and it's been the league's policy with
something like that in a suspension it
unless there's new evidence that comes
in whether you agree or disagree I don't
see it being shortened so if it's six
games how do you think this affects the
Dallas Cowboys sooner this is a you know
and this is the thing that I think this
young man needs to realize and I'm sure
TD
he's a generational back you know you
can't say that about a lot of players
you know he's a generational player he
really is and that offense that defense
everything benefits from that guy
now the offensive line is great and
they've got really capable backs backing
him up and I think they'll be fine will
the quarterback be asked to do more as a
byproduct will they will they be in more
in second and eight third and ten if
they are then the quarterbacks can be
asked to do more well I hope they don't
hopefully they look Derek fathoms go
slow no nor is Alfred Morris no he knows
and now I'm not off that offensive line
is that strength let me tell you
something is as advertised yeah that's
the string just just write them write
them and bacon well yeah but you know
you're you're gonna get the it's gonna
look like a punt block you know I mean
it's gonna be eight nine in the pan I
saw yeah yeah I go yeah so who do you
think wins the NFC then what do you
think you will be the nice outside of a
team that Chris is on I mean who do you
think wins this this conference that Fox
covers oil boy you know I think the
Giants are going to make a move I think
Atlanta is going to be there
I think Atlanta learned a lot of lessons
in the Superbowl and the question is can
you come back from that
psychologically I mean you look at
Seattle that that loss on the goal line
coming back close San Francisco that
loss on the goal line coming that close
those teams couldn't really recover from
that can they recover from that I would
say Carolina is in position from just
from a personnel standpoint cam has a
lot of weapons down there and if he's
healthy and he's going again and that
run games going again I think they're
going to be a real threat Green Bay is
going to be right there you look at the
quarterbacks it really comes back to the
quarterbacks as much that pains me to
say well I think it just shows that you
know cuz Seattle's in the mix too you
said in the last segment that we like
what they're what they're doing and that
acha room appears to be ready to maybe
they try bond you know they're a very
unique place they I am fascinated by
Seattle's culture I'm fascinated by that
defense Michael Bennett is one of my
favorite players Richard Sherman is one
of my favorite players camp Chancellor
is if you think you walked up on cam you
called him once a couple of Super Bowls
ago ago a card-carrying bad man here is
what you call you really really is I
mean he is he is like someone from my
you think about the guys that came out
in 81 with me I think it was Ronnie Lott
Mike Singletary Lawrence Taylor Ricky
Jackson Smith they see up in Denver
Kenny easily Ronnie Lott that was 81 now
those guys that were playing back there
would light you up kam chancellor is a
bigger version of all of those guys and
that's the NFC before I let you go I do
want to touch base on the Raiders and
how they appear poised as well I think
they've got the best chance to make sure
Tom Brady gets on an airplane for the
right to play in the Super Bowl this
year I really like their balance they've
got to get their left tackle in camp
when I think that that will end up
happening and the running game is it's
really the foundation of what they do
and you know this kid a quarterback I'm
excited for him to take yet another step
and Cooper and yeah it's a great group
and the additions they made not only on
offense but they made some additions in
the interior the defensive line through
the draft that are going to be really
exciting to help Khalil Marcus Khalil
Marquez is generational as well as a
generational playing you know rich we
throw that around too much but Khalil
Mack is yeah there's no question about
that our poll question today is what
would joxer's I wear bought nice day no
no no that's not it
that wasn't it that wasn't it dill to fo
Dell to fo is not George Bell to folks
exactly um from Jersey
the the poll question days what would
you rather win
a Super Bowl trophy or an Oscar an Emmy
in honor of you mr. Broken Arrow being
and Fred Dreyer I answer I have to say
this we touched on the Super Bowl
earlier with Chris I thought winning a
Super Bowl was great and it was and and
I thought getting in the Hall of Fame
was great to watch your son win a Super
Bowl I'll take that over all of that
it was I'm not by nature a Content
person you know there's always a you
know there's a there's another guy in
here talking in my head and you know I
have a history of violence and like that
movie there's there's still that
wrapping around in my head that was as
close to whatever Nirvana is as you can
get eating cheeseburgers at 4:30 in the
morning in the lobby of the hotel with
all of our boys and my wife and you know
our daughter-in-law and our grandson
that was for me
as good as it can possibly get
I thought the Super Bowl was great I
thought the Hall of Fame was great
watching your son win a Super Bowl by 10
he Clips that that's not even close to
getting the receipts of Broken Arrow
from open well I standing like that I
still my wife doesn't know but I still
do get residuals sneaker money don't
tell her she doesn't watch the show I
don't think but how much what does you
receive you what's less residual check
you got for Broken Arrow I think
probably like 300 bucks damn I'd take
her mone that's my kind of money I still
you know I still I mean I'm a 38 grand
my rookie year in the NFL yeah I'm
driving to use Coupe de Ville that's
$383 awesome oh I just got my glass
residual check from the episode of CSI
Miami in which I played in another two
dollars and 32 minutes I forget what the
show was I did it was a malcolm in the
modern or what it was some show i did in
in the 80s for just a walk-on cameo and
i got a $2 research FX don't have the
best and young how he said did you just
call them up and tell them save it
ha ha ha how you are the best you are
the best say how do you open i mean you
know that's how he longer having you
bene time please the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio stay
since across the country and audience if
you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy